So, it's my pleasure to
introduce our first speaker,
Dr. Robert Grossman.
He is the Director of the Center
for Data Intensive Sciences,
and a Professor in the Division
of Biological Sciences at the
University of Chicago.
He is a Core Faculty and Senior
Fellow at the Institute of
Genomics and Systems Biology,
and the Computation Institute.
He is also the founder and a
partner of Open Data Group,
which has been building
predictive models over big data
for Fortune 500
companies since 2002.
His topic and title of his
presentation today is Big Data &
Analytics: Five Trends
and Five Challenges.
Please join me in
welcoming, Dr. Grossman.
(Applause)
It's a real pleasure to be here.
I'm going to give a high
level talk about Big Data.
I'm going to assume you know
nothing about it, but assume you
care a little bit about it.
The term Big Data,
like Cloud computing,
doesn't mean anything anymore.
The simple way to tell when the
term doesn't mean anything is if
you're in an airport and waiting
for your luggage and you see a
term like Cloud computing or
Big Data then, from a research
perspective, you see the terms
in a large advertisement that's
10 feet by 20 feet, then that's
really a good sign that that
term doesn't mean anything
from a research perspective.
And so, Big Data is like that.
This is a 2012 report: Big Data,
Big Impact from the World
Economic Forum where they're
talking about how big data is
going to impact the developing
world so it's a nice term to use
but I'm going to try to dive
down a little bit into it.
So... the other way to realize
that there's a certain
trajectory to term is when
the term appears on the cover
of magazines like Science,
Nature, The Economist, and
Scientific America
and here are some covers.
The traditional way of looking
at big data is to measure it in
terms of bytes like megabytes
or petabytes and if you go to a
conference in data and people
have a couple beers you hear
them complaining that
when they reach a certain
level of petabytes their
file systems stop working,
their interconnects stop working
and so on, so there's clearly
an issue, as you get more bytes,
that certain things
begin to break.
The other way, because when
people popularize subjects,
they like alliteration, is to
talk about data in terms of how
much there is, how fast it
moves, what the variety is, etc.
And so, there's nothing wrong
with either of these methods but
they miss a little bit about
what's associated and has
transitioned in big data,
and so, I want to dive a
little bit further.
The simplest way to think
of data is that we always have
data, we always will.
We'll always have people who can
do something with it and we'll
always have people who throw
up their hands and complain.
What does change is every
few years the terms change.
I've been in the business
for about 35 years and I see,
more or less, the same problems.
I do notice there's an ebb and
flow to the meetings I go to so
around '96 to 2001 there was
sort of a real interest in large
data and that was associated
around the term "data mining
and knowledge discovery."
And, starting a few years
ago, maybe 5 years ago,
there was sort of a resurgence
of interest but, more or less,
there's been a continuous
trajectory as we've
changed the terms.
What you see on the Google
Trends is the blue is the term
"Data Mining" or "Knowledge
Discovery" and the red is the
term "Big Data."
So, if you look at the sum of
those two terms, nothing has
changed, but we use the
terms slightly differently.
I do think certain things have
changed, but it really is not
whether you call it data mining,
statistics, or knowledge
discovery, or
predictive analytics.
Chaitan and I were just talking
and if you want a different
perspective on data go to
a conference called Strata.
You can't believe anything
you hear at that conference,
unlike other conferences
where everything they say is
absolutely true with no
exaggeration, but it's still
important to go to a conference
like that because it fills sort
of a large exhibit floor the
size of a football field and
they're all doing things.
And one of the things different
there is many of them come from
companies where they have a lot
of data and they get fired if
they do stupid things with it,
so, there's a certain Darwinian
evolution that takes place and
the density of people who know
what's going on is maybe not
that great, but there are a lot
of them there that know a lot.
This definition is not a
bad working definition for
big data today.
Data is big today if it's too
big for your IT group to help
you work with it, and if you
need something else, then the
data is big.
So, you know, depending upon
whether you're Google or whether
you're a social science lab that
doesn't even get a data closet,
the size will change but the
problem remains that you have a
problem with managing your data.
I think one of the real things
that does change, and this is
because of the same law that
drives commoditization of
processors, you know, Moore's
Law, that gives us every 18-24
months, you know, that may
change in a few years, but right
now we have a tremendous
increase in our processing power
and so, we can do a level of
compute in every two years that
is just sort of unmanageable
several years before that.
That same commoditization
impacts sensors, and so,
you have sensors putting
out more and more data at lower
and lower cost.
And then, scientific
communities, as we're going to
discuss, organize their sensors
differently, but in each case,
the scientific communities
organize their sensors and put
out data and that's impacting
the data we see in research.
I think, perhaps, the most
fundamental transformation is
every decade or so, the way we
use these sensors changes and we
get incredibly new
modalities of data.
So, when I started doing
commercial, large big data,
in the mid-90's, there was
Internet click data and Points
of Transaction data and no
one knew how to analyze it.
People basically created what
now are called Beowulf clusters.
They created clusters of
computers, they created new
statistical techniques like
ensembles of models which fit
very well over clusters of
computers and over time they
were able to analyze
data at that scale.
Around 2000, a whole 'nother
type of data came out which is
the unstructured text data
on the web, and then, again,
what emerged was sort of the
map-reduced style that Google
introduced to analyze large
unstructured data that comes
up in search.
And that was actually
a fundamental change.
And then what's going on
now is there's yet another
transformation in which things
are moving from the Internet to
mobile and Internet of
Things and that's creating
a third revolution.
Now, one of the underlying
themes here is none of these
revolutions are from the
scientific side and in each of
these cases, for whatever
reasons, not only did the 10 -
or 100 - or 1000-fold increase
in data come from the industry
side, but the new techniques, in
terms of hardware and software
stacks came from there, too.
And in each case, at least in my
experience, the research lags
and then picks up these
techniques, sometimes a few
years later, but more
often a decade later.
And so, the transition
where a number of years ago,
high performance computing
and simulation would lead,
you see in data science that
researchers, by and large,
follow and that's for the simple
reason that if you are hired by
a large internet or mobile
company today, you will have
responsibility for working with
very large data sets with no
nonsense ability to deliver out
working models, and that will be
at least one or two orders
of magnitude larger than
what you would get the
way we train students at
most universities here.
So, there's a big gap and unless
your students go and intern in
one of these companies,
there's a big gap in how we
think of data.
Now, if you think of this from
a portfolio of discovery point
of view, just because data is
big doesn't mean the discoveries
are important and that's just
important to keep in mind.
We talk a lot about big data,
on the other hand, in terms of,
you know, we run a data
intensive computing facility
with several hundred users,
several petabytes of data that
is scientific research data
that's available for discovery
and I'm very interested
each year in the quality of
the science that comes.
Each month we give away
computing hours, over a petabyte
of data, that's about a million
dollars at Amazon rates for each
of our facilities,
and we have several.
And then you can ask,
is if we do a portfolio of,
we give this many, and so, I
think we have a couple million
core hours per facility and the
question is, if we could give
people, for data intensive
science, say 300,000 or half
a million that month versus
10,000 as we do that in
sort of a logarithmic
distribution in terms of core
hours over a petabyte of data,
you don't always get the best
science from the
largest allocation.
And so, you have to sort
of think of how that works.
And a simple example,
Netflix is small data.
My definition of small
means if it's in memory.
So, the Netflix prize, which was
a million dollar prize, was for
7 years of data, over half a
million customers, a hundred
million movie ratings, it was a
very tough statistical problem
to solve, but it was small in
the sense it fit into memory,
or it does basically fit
into a single work station,
and they designed that so they
could get 50,000 people to give
them free labor.
I've already alluded to this,
but I want to talk just for a
minute about the origins of
big data because I think it's
important before we go
back to the scientific data.
If you have data and you can't
manage it, there are three
things you can do in general.
You can change the hardware,
you can change the software,
or you could change the
algorithm, and then sometimes
you can change
the problem you ask.
Let's just look at how
we change hardware.
If we change hardware
there are two fundamental
things we could do.
We could do what's
called scale up.
We get more specialized hardware
by adding specialized components
or building specialized devices,
or we could do what's called
scale out where we add
more of the devices.
And when we do HBC, when we
do large data, we can take any
combination in this
two-dimensional space,
and the interesting thing is,
I mentioned there was a
new source of data which is
large amounts of unstructured
data from the web.
And Google made a series
of interesting choices.
A) They decided that they would
not follow the dominant paradigm
at that time, which was to use
fairly specialized computes with
a scale up and then use
a software infrastructure
called message passing.
Instead, they created what is
now called map reduce and the
Google file system and we
can use it in a hadoop and they
scale it out over commodity
components with a new software
infrastructure that's now part
of hadoop and sort of that
large ecosystem you
would see at Strata.
And that was driven by
computational advertising.
And why did computational
advertising drive that?
It drove it for the simple
reason that if you made a small
improvement in computational
advertising, you generated an
additional billion dollars.
And every time you had an
additional billion dollars,
you could save it to improve the
hardware and software stack and
that created a virtuous loop.
And we're going to hear later
from the NSF, but my current
understanding is, in data
intensive science, they spend
less than a billion dollars each
year, so that gave Google and
some of these others a strong
competitive advantage that build
year after year and
created this gap.
So, it is now a 120
billion dollar industry,
just online advertising.
This is the inside of Google's
Data Center, and this is
probably larger than the data
centers because it costs 400-500
million dollars than the data
centers at many universities.
The core software infrastructure
that came out was released in a
series of papers that
conveniently came out when
Google was working on
the next generation.
It was a software staff with
a very scalable file system,
a very scalable way to work with
unstructured text data over it,
and then a very
scalable database.
And this is a picture from a
couple years ago of the 120
billion dollar industry that is
around computational advertising
and created these
new techniques.
And this led to a new way of
talking about the size of data.
You talked about the size of
data in terms of the number of
megawatts of the data center
that controlled the data,
so, Facebook would say they're
building a new 30 megawatt data
center for, say, 300 million
dollars, and that would be to
not only hold the data,
but to analyze it and to
make it actionable.
So, that's sort of the unit, you
know, say 10 to 15 megawatts,
is the unit that they think of
of data, and one of the themes,
I think, that's interesting from
a research perspective is what
is the unit that we should
think of data from a research
perspective so that we can make
advances that are unimaginable
if we don't conceptualize
the problem right.
So, what is the
analogy of this unit?
I want to talk a little
bit about analytics.
That's some self tracking
data from someone walking
around San Francisco.
The reason I'm going to start
with analytics and then go to
statistical models, you know,
in research, what we need to do
is to take data, integrate it,
bring it together,
build statistical models, build
distributive statistical models,
and make discoveries.
So, we go from data
to statistical models to
discoveries to validation
and we have to do that in a
very scalable way.
The driving focus in
industry is analytics.
It's using, in the jargon of the
Fair Credit Reporting Act, FCRA,
is to build statistical models
that are statistically valid
and empirically derived.
I pulled from this ASA,
the American Statistical
Association website, their
current definition on their
website of statistics.
It's a much more complicated
story than this, but it's really
focused around uncertainty.
Some of the best advances in big
data come from statisticians,
but, there's a wide variety
within the statistical community
of, is big data real?
I mean, in a certain sense,
statisticians are right when
they say there is no
such thing as big data.
They're either empirically
driven and statistically valid
models or not.
On the other hand, as you get
new sources of data that are 100
or 1,000 larger than before, the
types of statistical models you
build tend to be different and
it's sort of that tension that's
one of the interesting focal
points of the field right now.
This is a very busy slide,
but occasionally, well once,
on an airplane, someone asked
me what I did and so, I tried to
explain what's happened in big
data in the last 40 years and
it's all in this slide.
My view these days is there's
very few changes, but once a
decade we get a change.
If you go to Strata and read the
slogans of the marketing people,
you feel that every 10 minutes
there's a change and it came
from that venture backed company
that's going to be gone in
10 minutes whose technology will
forever disappear, but from a
broader perspective,
there really hasn't been
that many changes.
So, the first change is
what we call the field.
That's now fundamental.
The second change is what kind
of conferences do you go to and
how nice are they?
When data mining came up the
conferences became much nicer in
much nicer places with much
nicer hotels than when it was
called computationally
intensive statistics.
And recently, with big data,
the conferences are even nicer.
So, I think from that viewpoint
there's been a real advance in
the field because the
conferences are much nicer.
If you read the proceedings of
one of these conferences every
year we get another 200
algorithms that are "from the
abstract, innovative and
are going to fundamentally
change the field."
On the other hand,
if you look back,
the number of algorithms
we get that are really
impactful, we seem to
get one a decade or so.
Sometimes we'll get a new
algorithm, we'll take an old
algorithm over larger compute
and change this name, say,
from NeuroNet to Deep Learning,
but we're still getting a new
algorithm every decade or so.
We had classification tree,
we have NeuroNets, then we had
classification regression trees,
we'd support vector machines,
we had a graph algorithm in the
page rank and now I don't know
quite what the
best algorithm is.
Every time I go to one
of these conferences I try
to take a vote.
Some people say
it's belief metrics.
Maybe it's the globally
distributed algorithms, but I'm
sure we have an algorithm and
we're going to figure out what
it is and we'll look back and
it'll be obvious, but we have
a lot of graph algorithms.
Pretty fundamental is, I talked
about the hardware set,
the software changes.
So, I talked about hadoop.
Hadoop really is useful and
it's being used in computing.
There's some issues with it.
We got R, we got PostgreSQL,
and then the scale which
we compute changes.
We went from a computer to
a Beowulf cluster; that is,
what could fit in a rack, to
a data center and I'm going to
come back to that because
one of the questions is what is
the analogy of a data
center for data intensive
computing for research.
And then, around 2011, Google
released algorithms that scale
across multiple data centers.
This is a very old problem, but
I've talked a lot about things,
but a lot of these
ideas are very, very old.
This is a problem that Abraham
Wald worked on in World War II.
The question was, how do you put
additional armor on airplanes?
I think most people have heard
this, but it's worth thinking
back about this.
Airplanes were being shot down
in World War II and if you armor
the whole plane it can't take
off, if you armor the wrong
places, it doesn't help, and
if you armor the right places
you save lives.
So, when they collect the data,
you can see when a plane comes
back where the bullet holes are,
so the question is, how do you
build a statistical model from
knowing where the bullet holes
are in an airplane that will
harden the airplane and allow
more airplanes to come back?
And notice the validation
is quite simple.
If you put a constant number of
airplanes in the field and you
assume that the adversary
is doing constant behavior,
then your algorithm works if
the number of airplanes that
comes back increases.
If you think about this, and
Abraham Wald did a model,
where you want to put the
armor is where the bullet holes
aren't because those are
the planes that didn't get
back and he wrote
a paper about that.
That is a nice example of what's
called selection bias and it's a
nice example that you still need
to think, no matter what the
software or hardware is, you
still really need to think about
the statistical and algorithms.
And so, that notion is still
very, very valuable today.
One of the themes here is the
bigger the data is the easier it
is to be stupid.
I want to stop about the
historical origins of big data.
The first emergence in terms
of data mining came with the
emergence of the Internet
and the data that came
from click streams.
The second renaissance with big
data came when people analyzed
data at the scale of a data
center from what Google's work
was, and talk about how
this looks like in Science.
And most of the time, when you
talk to people about big data,
they give you one example.
This is the example when a group
of researchers worked together
to come up with one theme.
It cost a billion dollars.
They get it funded, maybe 10
billion dollars, and they build
one instrument consisting of
lots and lots of small sensors
and they produce data.
Usually this takes 10 years and,
at the beginning of the 10
years, the amount of data that's
being produced looks scary,
but by the end of the 10
years when the instrument's
actually built, it turns out
to be a fairly modest amount
of data, if you know
what you're doing.
For example, the LHC, the Large
Hadron Collider, produces -
raw data is about 15 petabytes.
It's multiplied significantly as
it's analyzed, but the raw data
is 15 petabytes, which is not
a big number today, even though
the dry data is
quite a bit bigger.
Another modality for researchers
is when you have say hundreds to
thousands of labs producing,
again, instruments that produce
lots of data, but it comes on
these sort of midsized machines
that a lab might spend
a million dollars on.
From a couple years ago, this is
the sequencing machine that sort
of changed how NextGen
sequencing was done.
This is produced in aggregate,
a lot of data across biologies.
It created a crisis that, after
only 5 to 8 years of discussion
the biological community
created sort of a C change in
how they do things.
I'm going to talk a little
bit about that in my talk.
This is one of the
areas I work in.
This happened a
number of years ago.
We discussed it for a number of
years and we're beginning to
change the way we look at large
amounts of genomics data.
Something that's just happening
now is... raise your hand if you
have any self tracking device?
Okay.
Raise your hand if you know,
in addition to yourself -
this is unrelated to the talk,
I'm just sort of curious -
if, in addition to yourself,
what third party companies make
use of your self tracking?
Does anyone track carefully
who else has their
self tracking data?
Raise your hand.
Okay.
That's a whole 'nother talk,
but I'm not going to
talk about that.
But, this is changing things.
I'm going to come back to this.
One of the ways that people
think about this and, you know,
I think the MORE Foundation, the
Sloan Foundation, really took
a step in sort of trying to get
research universities to think
fundamentally about how to
do interdisciplinary science.
Now, the term Data Science was
introduced in industry a number
of years ago and it's also been
used for something pretty
different in academic research
for an emerging discipline.
And, again, this is sort of the
MORE and Sloan Foundations
agreed to work together in an
initiative around Data Science,
and so, this is the
term I'm going to use.
You could think of Data Science
as what happens when I take deep
math and stat, when I take deep
computer science and I take deep
knowledge of a field and
I bring them together.
The MORE Foundation and the
Sloan Foundation talk about
pie-shaped science.
Pie-shaped science
means you have two legs.
You have a leg into the
discipline where you have a
deep knowledge of the
discipline... biology, social
science, humanities... and you
have a leg into math, stat,
and computer science.
I split them, they don't;
and that you could bring those
things together to
create a new science.
And this is like any number
of sciences, starting with
statistics to computer science,
from an academic discipline
point of view, it's still up
in the air whether this is a
separate discipline or whether
there's a data science for
physics, a data science
for biology, a data science
for social science.
I think in some sense it
doesn't matter, but there are
interesting challenges that are
new in data science horizontal
or data science vertical.
In addition to showing you nice
things that happen, I also want
to give you a few
cautionary tales.
How many had salmon
in the last week?
Okay, you may not want
to listen to the next...
so, again, this is
pretty famous.
That's a picture of a salmon,
of the type we're going
to talk about.
And this is a poster
at a meeting.
I'll give you a
little more history.
There's a lot of research now
where they put people into FMRI
machines, show them pictures,
or tell them stories, or put
chemicals into them and see what
parts of the brain light up.
The experiment
was the following.
That's the salmon.
They took a dead salmon and
they put the dead salmon into a
functional MRI machine and
they applied exactly the same
algorithms that were used
in about 20% of the published
literature of these functional
MRI and emotional states and the
voxels that light up.
And they showed the dead salmon
pictures of happy humans and
pictures of unhappy humans and
it was a controlled experiment.
And then they identified
the voxel in the brain that
identified happy humans because
that's presumably important in
understanding the physiology
and the psychology of salmon.
And, for some reason, the
journal would not accept this
for publication, but they did
accept it as a poster paper
and, you know, the references on
here, underneath, on my slides,
you could see who did it,
but this is a classic problem.
It's a classic problem.
As you get more data,
it's easy to ignore
multiple independent tests.
There's standard techniques to
normalize out significant levels
when you have multiple
independent tests.
They were treating each of the
voxels as independent and asking
if it rose above the noise level
and then, without correcting for
the number of voxels, which is
thousands - tens of thousands.
And this problem
happens all the time.
It's a well known problem,
but that doesn't mean that the
papers that are published
are aware of the problem.
I've said this several times,
I just thought I'd remind you.
The bigger the data, the easier
it is to do something stupid.
Ah!
There were only 8,000 voxels.
A lot of scientists are doing
things and we have millions and
billions of models, so you
really have to think through
that you don't want to make
this simple voxel mistake.
So, I want to leave you with one
or two thoughts to think about.
The first thought is new
science, you know, I think a lot
about how to create, you know,
I'm the director of a center for
data intensive science at
the University of Chicago.
There are several other centers
around data at the University
and our center and the others
are thinking together and what
is the academic discipline
around data science.
And so, my point of view on this
is pretty simple, is that a lot
of times a new discipline
or a new modality of science
originates in an instrument.
So, in the same way microscopes
gave us an instrument to look at
small things and telescopes gave
us an instrument to look at far
things, we could ask what
is the instrument we need to
look at large data?
And it's kind of interesting to
see what the resolution increase
was in some of these instruments
that created new science.
So, for example, the telescope
gave you about a 30x increase in
resolution of the naked eye.
The microscope gave you about
a 250 increase in resolution
over the naked eye.
When I was starting my careers,
people were distinguishing the
theoretical and experimental
sciences for what they call
simulation science where you
would take a computer, here a
Cray computer, and do things
that couldn't be done before.
As best as I can tell from
looking at history, that first
Cray-1, which was a great
supercomputer and elegant in
design, gave you a 10 to 100x
increase in resolution in speed
over the high end
mainframes at that time.
If you do a back of the envelope
computation, the data centers
being built by industry give you
at least 100 fold increase in
resolution, the ability to do
statistically valid models over
data than what we have
in today's academic,
most academic institutions.
So, there are sort of
only two conclusions.
One, you could say, because of
all the things we're exposed to
in our diets these days, that
we're just not as smart as we
were in these other ages and
that even though we have an
instrument with maybe 10x
more resolution than the prior
instruments we're not going
to create a new science;
or, the other one is there's a
new science and we're going to
eventually figure it out.
It may not be interesting, it
may be interesting, but there'll
be something there.
I think a lot about how do
we build these instruments for
ourselves and this is sort of my
bet for what the instrument's
going to look like and where
I've spent the last 10 years
or so, thinking about.
We don't have a name and so
because someone here made the
mistake of inviting me to
give this talk I'm going to
call it a Cyberpod.
This is mainly to irritate
everyone in the audience so
you'll come up after the talk
and tell me that's the stupidest
name that I've ever heard and
why don't you call it, you know,
a tomato or something like that.
So, I'm going to
call it a Cyberpod.
It's something you
can afford to buy.
It's about the price of what
we pay for HPC, you know,
on sort of a national scale,
HPC efforts that, you know,
DOE and NSF fund.
That's a picture of a container
full of computers, so it's one
or two computers that run a
hardware and software stack
optimized for doing scientific
discovery over data and in 2004,
when the industry did this,
it was at least giving you 10
to 100 increase in the amount
of data you could build,
statistical models,
and make discoveries over.
One of the problems I've asked
myself, and I'll tell you a
little bit about it, but not
much, is if we had the right
Cyberpods and then, just as
there's a database is a way to,
sort of, in one specialized
scaled up machine - databases
drive a lot of science.
You can ask is there a data pod,
that is, a data software stack
over a cyberpod of data that
could drive data science and new
discoveries as they come up?
So, I think of cyberpods and
the software stack data pods.
And so, if we could take all
the nation's around the world's
cancer data and reanalyze it
every night, what would that
allow us to make in terms of
discovery and treatment that
we can't do today?
And so, this is not absurd.
In advertising, they may
advertise a billion individuals'
response in history to do the
best advertising algorithms for
the next day, you know,
it's done in other areas like
advertising, like high
performance trading, so the
question is, if those
disciplines can analyze all
of the data in a field and have
a paradigm to make discoveries
each day, why can't
we do that in science?
And so, this is the picture
that I have to summarize
the talk so far.
We have this paradigm of where
we get really, really smart
scientists, give them a small
amount of data and give them
years to make a discovery and
they work over gigabytes or
terabytes of data that is about
a watts of compute, and then,
at the other end, you can ask
this question: is there the
ability to work at the
megawatt level in cyber pods?
You would probably build simpler
models, but you could redo
them every day.
You could reanalyze the
data every day and, again,
I'm not arguing that one
side is better than others.
I'm arguing that why not have a
portfolio of solutions in which
you take whatever you can from
the whole spectrum of solution
space and not ignore one
end of the solution space?
And so, this is sort of the
division and there, you know,
we have one person driving this
whole process that reanalyzes
the data each day to make
discoveries with new data
coming in - all the text data,
all the genomic data,
all the associated
clinical data.
So, I now want to talk
about Five Trends.
I'm going to talk
about data commons.
One of the terms we can think of
using for that right-hand side
is a data commons.
Almost no one talks about
data commons except for a
few isolated colleagues.
This is the Google Trends
for the term "data commons."
If you compare that to
data mining or to big data,
this is a noise term.
That's buried in the noise.
It doesn't even
arise above the noise.
So, in the genomic sciences
the paradigm has broken because
researchers who have a petabyte
of genomic data, any researcher
who has a petabyte of genomic
can afford to have their own
infrastructure, can afford
to hire the data scientists,
the data engineers,
etc., to analyze it.
So, we were forced, after
only five years of discussion,
to create this other paradigm
in which we have a commons.
And here, I'm defining a commons
where we co-locate data storage
and computing infrastructure
commonly used tools for
analyzing sharing data to create
a resource for the community.
And so, the question is how do
we create commons at scale that
can interoperate with
scientists' own infrastructure,
that could peer with each other
and that can change the way
we do data science at scale.
And I'm not going
to talk about them.
Our team, you know, we created
a not for profit called the
Open Commons Consortium
to do this, has created a
series of these for
the last several years.
We created something called the
Open Science Data Cloud, which
has about a petabyte of data,
and I referred to that before.
That was supported by the MORE
Foundation for three years.
We created something called the
Bionimbus Protected Data Cloud,
another petabyte of
infrastructure which could hold
genomes and clinical data
from large cancer projects
funded by the NCI.
We're building, and it's in beta
testing, and so, if you guys are
bored and don't have anything to
do, you could beta test this.
The NCI Genomic Data Commons is
an infrastructure that's going
to hold research data from all
National Cancer Institute funded
projects and any NCI funded
researcher and they, as part of
their funding, are required to
put their data into a commons
and it's the NCI
genomic data commons.
It's in beta now, and be
released in a one-level release
in November and another
release in May for general use.
And then, the NOAA also has a
commons for all their data and
we're building one of them.
And then Amazon,
Google, IBM, Microsoft
are also building commons.
Ours is focused on the
research community.
This is a picture of the
Genomic Data Commons.
It has, today, two
petabytes growing to five
petabytes of data.
We analyze all that data as a
common analysis, the data that
comes in has, by and large,
been analyzed either by single
research groups or by the
centers that put them together,
so this is a reanalysis of all
the data and we're designing a
system that could reanalyze
all NCI funded data.
Every few months, we like to
scale up the infrastructure so
we could do it
even faster than that.
We downloaded the two petabytes
of data and processed it
in real time.
QC redid the alignment and
etcetera and this is a picture
from a part of a day.
Each of those lines is a file.
The time is horizontal and it's
the length of time it took us to
process it from files that are
almost a terabyte in size that
we downloaded, two files that
are megabytes and gigabytes.
I think it's a half
a million files.
We brought it in at 8 or 9
gigabytes per second for weeks
to analyze it.
I like to do things that are
simple, so once you have data
that no one else has
done you could do pretty
simple statistical models.
So, this is a statistical model
we built where the gray are
adenocarcinoma, it's a
particular type of lung cancer.
The purple are
squamous cell carcinoma.
We took the RNA seek data.
We did principle components
analysis in about 400 dimensions
and we just built some simple
statistical models and the
green are things that
seem to be misclassified
under this analysis.
It's about 10% in there.
There's a drug, Avastin, that
works for one that doesn't work
for the other.
It actually shortens
your life in about half
if it's misapplied.
So, this is an example of a
relatively simple statistical
model that could only be done
when you have enough data that
has a huge impact, that's
relatively simple to do as long
as you have access to the
data and could do statistical
analysis at scale.
I want to talk about
the second trend.
This is really analytics of
things, people, and places.
We have urban sensors that
we're putting into Chicago.
There are a number of
instrumenting cities.
This is the idea that to
understand urban science,
let's instrument a city, that's
a conceptual version because the
actual sensors in Chicago are
much uglier, but that's what
they thought it would look like
before they actually built it.
They're actually putting sensors
into all sorts of things, so you
could put sensors into waste
bins and other things in cities,
so, cities are going to be
instrumented and produce lots of
data that's going to change how
we think about urban science.
I think most people have this,
but there's also people are
going to be producing lots of
data that will change how we
think about social science and
health science, and places are
going to generate data.
Many cars have phones or
devices that emit probes.
The purple is where people brake
and you could observe that the
cars that don't brake
in the right place can't
navigate the curve.
So, I use the term kouros
space, Greek kouros for place,
to be the analytics
associated with place.
So, as you have things giving
off data, people giving off
data, you can annotate space
in interesting ways and here we
could, if we see a car not going
slow enough, you could inform
the car, inform the driver, that
if they don't slow down they're
not going to be
able to navigate that.
And this is a very simple model
that is clear to how to build
once you have enough data.
My third trend is we're not
doing sometimes very deep
computer science for big data
and I'd like just to remind
people, we've talked about the
software stack that does new
programming paradigms,
I haven't talked about
the networking stack.
The data centers have
new types of networks.
But, I do want to mention that
one of the most powerful things
we have in computer science
is the ability to use languages.
So, right now, we think of
computer scientists as heroes
that can do whatever they want
with no discipline and as long
as they get an answer
out we're happy.
But, why not give them tools and
force them to use the tools?
For example, there are
languages for graphics.
My colleague, Leland Wilkerson,
wrote a very influential book
called The Grammar of Graphics,
so that when we did
visualization in exploratory
data systems we could really do
that with grammar so that we can
manipulate the language that
describes the graphics
instead of always
manipulating the graphics.
I've spent about 15 years
of my life building models for
analytics so that, at scale,
when we have lots of models
like that, we work with
the models using a language.
It was first a predictive model
markup language, now the
portable format for analytics,
and this allows you to scale
up to cyberpods and data
centers, how you build
analytics at scale.
And if you think about
visualization, I pull out D-3,
but there are others that
allow you to describe what
you want to do, not how
you want to visualize.
The fourth trend is, you know,
there are policies and they're
going to create other policies
that are going to encourage
people to make data available.
The government is now asked to
make data available under the
Exec Order 13642 from May '13,
and the guidance from OMB.
That led to the NOAA,
which was the first agency to
operationalize this in terms of
a CRADA, that is a cooperative
agreement that allowed our
consortium and IBM, Microsoft,
and Google to partner with NOAA
to have access to any of the
20 petabytes to make it
available to, in our case
researchers, to the other
companies to mainly companies,
but that was driven
by the OMB initiative.
There's also initiatives
for preservation and others,
thoughts about reproducibility,
so there's a C change coming and
we don't really have the
infrastructure to do that.
And then, I'm going to talk
about the last trend and then
leave time for Q&A...
Is that clock right?
Okay, good.
A lot of times, they put
me in places where the clocks
are wrong, just to challenge me.
Early in my career, I did math
and the nice thing about math
that doesn't apply to anyone.
The last little bit of my career
I'm a little more interested in,
as you do things like data
science, can it apply to anyone?
And so, I'm going to
talk about what I call
translational data science.
So, the term "translational" was
created a number of years ago
around this notion that there
was a big lag between how long
it took a basic discovery in
biology or medicine to go from
the lab to the patient.
And so, if we think of this as
informatics in general, we have
bioinformatics at the
molecular and cellular level,
imaging informatics,
clinical informatics,
public health informatics,
but we have translational in
each of those things.
And so, translational
informatics is something that
people have been
struggling with for 10 years.
So, one of the things that's
been motivating us in our center
is what you might call
translational data science;
that is, if you don't just think
about the discovery but you
think about how to accelerate
the impact of that discovery on
populations or patients or
society, there's this notion
that we spend all our time
thinking about the hardware,
software, and modeling but most
of the translational effort is
setting up the infrastructure,
getting the data on one side and
then deploying the model
and checking it and making
it actionable on the other.
And the actual modeling
is a very small component.
So, if you want to optimize the
translational impact you have
to have things like
languages for deployment.
That's why we created a
portable format for analytics.
You have to create standard
systems like cyberpods to take
care of the data so that you
can impact the whole thing.
So, we think of the data
engineering, data science,
and applications, in this case
to genomics analysis of medical
records, etc., where we could
get discoveries, diagnosis,
and therapeutics out as
being sort of a way to do
translational data science.
This is some example of that
where we're trying to take large
amounts of environmental,
electronic medical records and
try to understand how
we can make impacts.
And this is the distribution
of two diseases.
One clearly relates to
the physical environment.
That turned out - we
just analyzed the data.
It was about 100 million
medical records.
The top turns out to
be a well known disease.
And we rank-ordered about
1,000 diseases by ICD 9 codes
from those that have most
geospatial variation to those
that have least.
And then we were doing a
simple classifier to ask it,
is the geospatial variation
due to environmental,
socioeconomic, structure,
like payer-provider, or other?
And the top is something
that's clearly physical when
you look at it.
The middle, it's not so obvious
what that is, but that's
really socioeconomic driven.
And then you can see things that
are payer-provider because they
split very much on
the jurisdictional lines.
So, I want to end
with five challenges.
I think the one that's probably
most to my hard, and maybe the
hardest is this sort of way that
Phil Anderson, a Nobel Prize
winning physicist
asked the question.
He summarized his work in
basically solid state physics as
really being concerned with the
question is at scale, you know,
as you add more and more things,
are there new emergent behavior
that's really different.
And there's this famous
Science article in '72 called
"Is More Different?"
And I think, to me, this is
the fundamental question.
A lot of statisticians believe,
and are certainly right at some
level, that there is no such
thing as big data, there is only
good and bad statistics.
On the other hand, at a
phenomenological level, you sort
of believe as you go to scale
certain phenomena appear that
just don't appear and that
certainly is the case in solid
state physics and, to me, the
question in data science is -
one of the outstanding questions
is - what discoveries can we
make in data science that show
emerging properties that just
aren't there at smaller scale?
The second challenge I've
alluded to sometimes is one
I've been working on.
It's one of the reasons we
created the Commons for Genomic
and Clinical Data is - and doing
a million genomes was part of
the Presidential Precisional
Medicine Initiative -
at $1,000, it's roughly a
billion dollars of sequencing,
but if there's about a
terabyte of data as we get more
data for patients, a million
terabytes is a thousand
petabytes is an exabyte,
that's something that is
outside of what we could
easily do in science today.
But, it would probably
fundamentally change because
cancer and other diseases
are about combinations
of rare variance.
We don't have the statistical
power, we thought we did,
00:53:51.295,00:53:51.228
but every time we think we do,
we're sort of surprised by the
complexity of cancer, but a
million - you know, you hope
that with a million genomes, an
exabyte of data, that you would
have an understanding.
But understanding statistics
at that level is really
a big challenge.
The other one I'm going to say
is how do we create tools for
research communities, data pods,
and pod bases that allow us to
easily give open source
infrastructure that's simple and
easy to manage to researchers
so they have instruments for
discovery at the scale that
data science sometimes asks.
I actually have 10 challenges,
but I only have time for 5,
so, as we get to challenge 4
and 5, sometimes they're above
and below the line.
I think this is an
interesting problem.
We know how to deal with
a billion feature vectors.
We know how to deal
with a million dimensions.
I don't think we have a very
good understanding of how we can
semi automate the production of
a billion statistical models and
make sure that we can
validate them and understand.
So, one of the things I'm
interested in is how do we scale
up our ability to work
with very, very large
numbers of models.
And, again, if you think back
on some things I've said about
languages, infrastructure,
pods, it's really - this is
parts of it.
And the last one, we
have something called HCI,
Human Computer Interaction.
I think it might be interesting
to imagine what a human data
science interaction is.
Initially, it was
the data science and
statistician doing everything.
There was a period of time when
the statistician did nothing.
I actually think there's sort of
a nice interesting middle ground
where the data scientist steers
these very large systems and
it's sort of a good time.
People with mechanical turk,
they have a lot of things,
but, how can we bring the
human back into this loop to
scale things up?
And so, every year or so, I post
a blog so I'm due for one,
so, I'm going to put the
9 or 10 challenges up there
and some references.
But, that's all I have
to say for today.
(Applause)